join me as we unbox this adorable Anya
farja package flown all the way from
Japan so Kawaii this is a noodle stupid
figuring of Anya and oh wait
I get to do it now let's open this baby
up Anya sits in this beautifully wrapped
plastic casing oh she's fine wakuwaku
it's Anya's interchangeable head why not
put it in
and of course this is me trying to
embody Anya now let's test her out
Simply open up your cup noodle and fill
it up with hot water Fork nah Fork that
onion is the way to go
oh it's not the end of the world Anya
the figuring is stunning and
interchangeable hits at even more value
okay time for me to enjoy my noodles
with Anya